[ Music ]
>>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome back
Vic Gundotra.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Wow!
Good morning, everybody.
This place is packed.
I'm surprised so many of you made it back
after that great party last night.
You know, let me begin by just thanking you
guys for your support.
Yesterday was an epic day for Google I/O.
It was quite an amazing day.
And just thank you for being part of that.
I hope you enjoyed it as much as we did.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And I hope you're enjoying
your Android development kits.
Yes?
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right.
You know, that party last night, thank you
for many of you who downloaded the new version
of Google+ for Android and then accepted my
invitation.
We had over 2600 of you do that.
And of those 2600 people, over 1,000 people
turned on Party Mode and contributed over
13,700 photographs from last night's concert.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: When was the last time you
went to an event and the next day had that
many photos automatically organized and chronological.
I have to apologize.
This is not Glass that's distracting me.
Ever since yesterday, I've developed just
this nervous TIC.
I am just always wondering, where is Sergey?
I'm not sure if he's in the building, if he's
above the building.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: As you probably know, he's
going to do some fun stuff again today.
I hope you've been following his Google+ posts.
But I think you're likely to see some pretty
exciting stuff.
With that, let's get started with day two
keynote.
I think you're going to be really excited
about what you're going to see here.
That's going to be handled by our senior vice
president of Chrome and apps, and my friend,
Sundar Pichai.
Sundar.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Music ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you.
Welcome to day two of Google I/O keynote.
It's very exciting to be here.
None of what I have planned involved jumping
from an airplane, doing anything on top of
Moscone or riding onto the stage.
But we nevertheless have lots of exciting
stuff ahead.
In fact, we've had a few exciting months.
But a few months ago, we launched Chrome for
Android, which, hopefully, all of you can
use on your brand-new Nexus 7.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: About ten weeks ago, we launched
Google Drive.
And just about three weeks ago, we launched
a whole new next-generation line of Samsung
Chromebooks.
And we are just getting started.
What we thought we'd do today was to take
a step back, talk to you about the journey
we are on and where we are going next.
I'm primarily going to be talking about Chrome
and our cloud applications, our journey to
help you all live online in the cloud seamlessly.
We'll also talk about the Web platform, what
we are doing so that developers like you can
write great Web applications.
So let's get started.
The chart behind me shows the growth of the
World Wide Web, shows the growth of traffic,
the Internet traffic.
And as you can see is the top line is the
total traffic.
It's exploded.
In fact, since the advent of broadband, it's
grown a lot and reached today over 2.3 billion
users, a staggering number.
But the good news is, this is only one-third
of the world's population.
And the way we are going to get to the rest
of the world is through mobile.
That's what the second line shows.
With the advent of smartphones and better
connectivity, increasingly, people are accessing
the Web for the first time ever on their phones.
And with the help of mobile, we are going
to reach the entire world's population.
In fact, it's expected in about four years
there are going to be around 20 billion network
connections, about 2.5 network connections
for every user in the world.
We are in the middle of a revolution.
At Google, we saw this trend coming, which
is why we built Chrome.
About three and a half years ago, we launched
Chrome as a browser to help showcase the modern
Web.
And we are very excited and humbled to see
that option.
Thanks to a lot of users and developers like
you, about two years ago at Google I/O, we
announced that we have 70 million weekly active
users.
A year ago, we announced we had doubled to
160 million active users.
And as of today, we have almost doubled again,
to 310 million active users.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: What matters, though, is
that how people use Chrome.
They live on it every day.
Every single day, there are over 60 billion
words typed in Chrome.
That is the equivalent of 100,000 textbooks,
or one terrabyte of data, documents, text,
images, videos are downloaded every single
day.
And, finally, something which is near and
dear to my heart, Chrome is all about speed.
Just one feature in Chrome, the fact that
when you're typing in the Omnibox, we try
to guess where you go, prefetch and prerender
the page.
That feature alone saves 13 years of human
lifetime every single day in Chrome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: And we have hundreds of such
features in the product.
We are very humbled by this momentum.
There's a lot of conversation about share,
et cetera.
By our internal metrics and everything we
see out there, Chrome is the most popular
browser in the world globally.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: The landscape has changed
pretty significantly since we launched Chrome.
At the time we launched Chrome, most of you
were using the browser on a single computer.
It was primarily the desktop Web.
Fast forward to today.
Almost all of you have smartphones.
You have a computer at home, at work, you
share your devices with family and friends,
and increasingly, you're buying tablets.
So Chrome was built for a better Web.
But for today's Web, we want to make sure
Chrome acts as a layer so that your Web is
personalized, works consistent and seamlessly
across all your devices.
To show you how we are doing that, let me
invite Brian Rakowski, our vice president
of product management, but more formally known
as the inventor of Incognito mode.
Brian.
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: Thanks, Sundar.
If you guys are anything like me, you probably
use Chrome across a lot of different computers.
In fact, you probably just use a lot of different
computers, computers, devices, phones, tablets,
all sorts of different things.
I counted.
I use about eight different computers on a
regular basis.
And I'm sure a lot of you use many more than
that.
So to show you how Chrome makes that experience
painless moving across all these different
devices to get stuff done, living life in
the cloud, I'm going to show you what I do
on just a typical day with Chrome.
Here I am at home on my MacBook.
Over breakfast, I'm reading news, catching
up on current events.
You see I have a whole bunch of tabs open
here.
Some of them I've read.
Some of them I haven't read yet.
You can see I've got my books marks here,
Chrome has been customized over the last several
years of using Chrome to have all my settings,
everything that makes Chrome work well for
me.
But I'm running out of time.
I've got to get out to work.
I run out the door, leave my Macbook, and
head to work.
Now I'm at work.
Not too bad of a commute today.
Here I am on my Chromebook, and it turns out
I use a different computer at work than I
do at home.
In fact, I use a lot of different computers
at work.
As a member of the Chrome team, we're always
testing new hardware.
We're always trying out new devices, reinstalling
Chrome, Chrome OS on different things.
So I end up using lots of different computers
every day to get stuff done.
It turns out on this computer, I've never
actually signed up.
I don't have an account on this computer.
So because I've never used it before, I'll
just sign in with my user name and password.
If I got that right, all my settings will
start coming down from the cloud.
These are all my settings on the Macbook.
And in addition, I've customized Chrome to
start up with some work tabs when I'm at work.
So when I hit "okay," you should see my work
tabs just appear on the screen.
There they are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: So you can see, I've got
my bookmarks here, all my settings are down
here, also these tabs, I can get some work
done, see the tree is open.
That's good.
PRD I've been working on for incognito.
I can file some bugs.
All this work is kind of making me hungry.
It's time for lunch.
Let's think about what to have.
I feel like something salty, maybe a little
bit more of a hearty meal, some pork maybe.
I heard about this place, but I can't remember
the name.
Something to do with -- with pig.
Let me try to query.
Let's see what happens.
Salty pig parts.
[ Laughter ]
>>Brian Rakowski: Boccalone.
Okay.
That sounds like it might be the place.
Let me click.
Yes.
That's --
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: -- that's what I'm looking
for.
Okay.
And it looks like there's a location in the
Ferry Building.
So let me click that.
Okay.
Not too far.
I can just walk there.
So leave work, head out the door, and as I
walk to the Ferry Building, I realize that
I was so distracted by those pictures of delicious,
delicious pork products that I forgot exactly
where the location of the place was.
In fact, I wasn't paying attention to it at
all.
But it's not a problem, because I've got Chrome
installed on my phone, and I'm signed in here,
too.
So I'll just -- let me zoom in a little bit.
I'll just launch Chrome, open a new tab, and
you can see all my recent devices.
You can see the Chromebook I had open at work.
And that tab is still open there.
I can pull it over here.
So I'll click the Ferry Building.
And that page should load right here so I
can see exactly where I need to go.
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: Now, turns out we didn't
just sync that URL.
We also made sure that the back button works
across pages.
So after I've gotten in line, I can start
to look at the menu by tapping back.
And I can even go back to search results.
So back works across devices as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: So now that I'm happily
eating my lunch, turns out I'm a little bit
of a nerd.
I carry a second device around with me.
When I want a bigger screen, I've got my brand-new
Nexus 7.
And, of course, Chrome is installed there,
too.
I've already signed in and started to set
it up.
Just -- and since I'm having this delicious
sandwich, let's say I want to visit a site,
it's a blog I haven't been to in a while.
I think it's called hamburger -- it showcases
the best hamburgers every single day that
they can find.
So I'll just start typing -- and because Chrome
is synced, even though I've never typed this
URL on this device before, I typed it on one
of my other computers, it's synced here, saves
me a lot of typing.
And even better, as Sundar mentioned, we're
pretty obsessed with speed.
We've started to load this page in the background
because we know you're very likely to go there.
As soon as I tap this, it should be there
waiting.
Ready, one, two, three.
And the page is already loaded.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: So I can load a page there,
enjoy my lunch.
Everything will be delicious.
So I've shown you Chrome syncing across a
couple different laptops, including a Chromebook,
a phone, a tablet, all my settings, including
my open tabs, my bookmarks, all the things
that make Chrome work for me, synchronizing
silently in the background, making it painless
to live across all these different devices.
But there's one more thing I wanted to talk
to you about.
Some of you have been very persistently asking
for one thing in particular.
And before we agreed to do it, we wanted to
make sure that we did an excellent job of
it.
I'm very happy to say that the team has really
pulled something great out.
So you're probably wondering what it is I'm
talking about.
People have been asking -- you've been asking
-- to use Chrome on your iPhone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: So I'm happy to announce
that later today, Chrome will be rolling out
in the Appstore.
But I'll give you a sneak preview now.
Here's Chrome on my home screen.
Launch it, and it should look very familiar
to any of you who have used Chrome on another
device before.
If you use Chrome on Android or a Chromebook,
you'll see it's got an Omnibox up top.
It behaves just like you'd expect it to.
You can open tabs, as many tabs as you like.
You can flick through them easily, quickly.
It's a silky smooth experience, really fun.
You can select the one you're looking for.
You can even close tabs with a quick swipe.
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: And if --
>>Brian Rakowski: And you can even swap tabs
without having to go to the switcher just
by dragging from the side.
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: Makes browsing the Web on
your iPhone really fun.
But while we were at it, we figured, why stop
there?
We might as well go for the iPad, too.
So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: And you can even swap tabs
without having to go to the switcher, just
by dragging from the side.
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: Makes browsing the Web on
your iPhone really fun.
But while we were at it, we figured why stop
there.
We might as well go for the iPad, too.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: So I'll give you a sneak
preview of that as well.
Here is Chrome on the home screen of my iPad.
Launch it.
You can see we've put the tabs up top here
just like we did on the Nexus 7.
We've got a little more space to work with
that makes multi-tasking easier.
I've got a bunch of tabs open here and you
can see they've started to pile up because
I've got a few too many open.
That's not unusual.
But I can just push them out of the way to
get to the one I'm looking for.
It's a really nice overflow solution when
you have a lot of tabs open.
And just like all the other devices, it's
synced.
Everything is here.
So you can see I have my bookmarks from my
desktop, find anything I'm looking for, and
all my other devices are here.
So you can see everything I've done today.
You can see I've got all those restaurant
pages open on my iPhone, you can see my Nexus
7 where I was looking at food over my lunch,
you can see the salty pig parts query which
I backed up from on the Boccalone site, the
work that I did today -- looks like I didn't
do much at all.
And you can see the pages I had open on my
MacBook Pro this morning over breakfast.
In case I want pick up where I left off on
one of those pages, I'll just tap it and finish
reading the news and it will load here.
Everything just works across devices.
But in this case -- oh, it looks like I need
to log in.
Well, it's not a problem.
My credentials are linked across machines.
Even though I've never used the "New York
Times" on this device before, never logged
in, I can just tap "log in," and because I'm
signed in, my credentials are synced, auto
fill, you can log in directly.
[ Applause ]
>>Brian Rakowski: Now, one more feature before
I quit, Incognito, a feature near and dear
to my heart, the team did a great job with
Incognito here.
You can see it works just how you would expect
it to from other computers.
You can toggle between regular and Incognito
windows just by tapping there.
And having Incognito on a touch device is
a great experience.
Thank you.
Sundar, back to you.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you, Brian.
It's an exciting demo to see Chrome on Android
phones, Android tablets and now on the iPhone
and the iPad.
So no matter which device you're using, we're
working really hard across all important software
platforms.
No other browser vendor is doing this.
We want to make sure it's about the user,
your Web, working everywhere, personalized,
consistent, always, any time, anywhere.
Of course, when you're living online and living
in the cloud, you're using cloud applications.
And at Google we realized this, and in 2004
there was a profound shift on the Web.
The Web shifted from documents to be about
rich, interactive Web applications.
And in 2004 we launched one of the seminal
AJAX applications of that era, Gmail.
And since then Gmail has grown to reach 425
million active users, monthly unique users,
and it's become a primary communications platform
for all these users.
We haven't stopped there.
We've been very hard at work and we've continually
added more applications.
Google Calendar, Google Documents, Google
Spreadsheets, Google Presentations, and about
ten weeks ago we launched Google Drive, a
centralized place for you to create and collaborate
online and have all your important data with
you so that you can live in the cloud.
We call this Going Google, and hundreds of
millions of users have gone Google.
But it's not just at home.
There is a very powerful trend underway.
We call this consumerization of businesses.
It's the same person who leaves home and shows
up at work, and they demand the same experience.
Smartphones are a good example.
People have demanded the same smartphones
at work like they've used at home.
The same is true for their applications as
well.
This trend has been so powerful, we are seeing
many, many businesses are Going Google.
In fact, governmental agencies in 45 out of
50 states in the U.S., including places like
Department of Interior, have gone Google.
66 of top 100 universities in the United States
have gone Google.
And over five million businesses, the rate
at which we are signing up businesses is growing
steadily, have gone Google.
This is a pretty fundamental shift.
If you look at most businesses, they are based
on the PC architecture.
And the PC, which was a huge revolution, was
primarily focused on automating your individual
work space.
Fast forward to today.
Most companies are in -- care about collaboration
deeply, and you're just not going to get there
by using SharePoint or TPS reports.
What you need is a radical different architecture
to get there, which is why many, many large
companies are Going Google.
You can see many big names up there.
Let me give you one example.
Roche, which has 90,000 employees over 140
countries.
They acquired Genentech, which is a Google
Apps customer, and Roche has decided to deploy
Google across their entire employee base.
So it's a very, very powerful trend.
We call this trend Going Google and we put
together a few short videos to show you what
it is like to go Google.
Let's take a look.
[Video]
>>> So yeah, I think we're good.
I think that about wraps it up.
>>> Great.
I'll send a follow-up email.
>>> I don't -- there's nothing much to follow
up on, so --
>>> Well, we should regroup.
>>> We just regrouped.
This is the regrouping.
>>> Cool.
I'll ping you later.
>>> You're pinging me now.
What do you want to ping about?
>>> Next steps.
>>> There are no next steps.
We just solved it.
>>> All right.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>>> Oh, here she comes.
She's a scary lady.
[ Laughter ]
>>> She's an angry tiger.
She's a mangobbler.
Eater.
She's a maneater.
Oh, here she comes.
Watch out, boy, she'll chew you up.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: As I said earlier, this is
a fundamental and radically different way
to collaborate.
Just try doing that with SharePoint.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sundar Pichai: But ten weeks ago we launched
Google Drive, one more step in this journey.
In just over ten weeks over 10 million users
have signed into Google Drive, they're creating
and collaborating both with Google applications
and third-party applications, and storing
all their important data.
And this is another step in our journey to
help users go Google.
To talk about our journey with drive, I'd
like to invite Clay Bavor, director of product
management for Google Apps.
[ Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: Thank you, Sundar.
As Sundar said, Google Drive is all about
making it really easy to live life in the
cloud.
And that starts by making all of your files
available on all of your devices anywhere.
And to do that we've built a really nice Web
interface, desktop sync applications for Windows
and for Mac, and also a really, really nice
Android app, but like with Chrome we want
Drive to be available on every platform, so
today I'm really excited to announce we're
making it available on iOS and on Chrome OS.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: So let me start here on iOS
here on the iPad.
I'm just going to zoom out a bit.
And I'll just open up Drive.
You can see the interface is really, really
fluid.
It works just like you'd expect.
You can browse through dozens and dozens of
file types.
Here I'll pull up a photo.
It's a bigger photo than I remember.
And everything just works like you'd expect,
but it's not just browsing that we've made
available on the iOS experience.
We've brought a lot of the best features of
Drive right to the mobile and tablet experience.
So for example, I'm going to open up this
folder of receipts here.
I'm a big nerd.
I scan all of my receipts, but I was also
too lazy to actually title any of these.
But I know that somewhere in here there's
a receipt from the post office with a tracking
number.
So what I can do here is just search -- and
I'm going to type "certified mail."
I think that word was in there somewhere.
And just like that I can pull up
the receipt.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: Notice this isn't a text file.
There's no text in here.
I haven't written anything.
Instead we used optical character recognition
technology to actually extract the text from
the scan, index it and then make it searchable.
Now, the cool thing is that doesn't just work
with text.
[ Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: Yeah, it's pretty cool.
It doesn't just work with text, it works with
photos, too.
Let me show you what I mean.
So here I have a big pile of photos.
I took a trip with my wife through Africa
last year, and I know somewhere in here are
photos of us at the pyramids, but again, I
didn't title my photos, I didn't add keywords,
but if I search for pyramids, just do a search,
up come the images of us at the pyramids.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: So again, we can actually use
image recognition technology to peer inside
of the images to actually understand the content.
I don't have to do anything, no labels, no
metadata, no nothing.
It just works.
Of course, I don't always have an internet
connection, so Drive makes it really easy
to just save things, cache them offline.
So here I'll just save this manual offline
so I can read it whenever.
And of course, at its core Drive is about
enabling sharing and collaboration.
So I can add users to collaborate in documents
with me right from the app.
So here's I think a relevant document here.
I haven't gotten very far, but I'm going to
add Brian right here.
He's now backstage.
And we'll see if he has any other ideas, give
him edit access.
I've added him right there.
We'll come back to that in a second.
So that's Google Drive on iOS to be available
for iPad, iPhone, iPod Touch later today.
Check it out.
I think you'll like it.
[ Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: So if we can go over to the
Chromebook now, I want to show you Drive on
Chrome OS.
So with Drive on Chrome OS, what we did was
actually integrate it deep into the operating
system.
So what I can do here is I'm just going to
open up my application tray, open up files,
and basically Google Drive is just the file
system.
It's your hard drive in the cloud.
And we sync down everything silently so that
you can all of your stuff whenever you need
it everywhere, right there.
So of course, Drive does a lot more than just
sync your files to the cloud.
It enables some amazing applications.
And one of those is real time collaboration
in the cloud with applications like Google
Docs.
So I'm going to open up this document here.
There we go.
And I'm also going to pull it up on my smartphone
and on my tablet.
Here is on my smartphone.
[ Laughter ]
>>Clay Bavor: Show some LOL cats.
>>Clay Bavor: And here's everything synced
across all of my devices.
Keystroke by keystroke I can see these edits.
Everything just works.
Now, this last point is an important one.
Google Docs works great if you're connected
to the internet, but what if you're on a plane
or you don't have a connection?
What about then?
We've been thinking about that and we're really
excited to announce that today Google Documents
works for editing offline.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: So let me show you how this
works.
So what I'm going to do is we've turned out
of wireless on the laptop here and I'm just
going to unplug the ethernet cable.
So there it is, it's unplugged.
And just to prove to you that I am offline,
"New York Times," no connection, but I can
just go back to my Google Doc and I can keep
editing just like I'm online.
All the formatting still works, and you'll
see that Google Docs has just noticed gracefully
I'm offline.
All my changes are just saved locally to a
local cache and I can keep on without even
thinking about it.
It all just works without me even noticing.
So what I'm going to do now is I've made some
changes offline, maybe Brian and folks backstage
are making some more changes.
I'm going to close this document, all my changes
are saved, I'm going to plug ethernet back
in, and now watch what happens when I open
the document, because it's going to happen
pretty quickly.
I'm going to open it back up in Drive and
like that it will be synced back to the cloud
and you will see it across all of my devices
updated in real time.
So let me open up the Drive Web interface.
Here it is.
I'm going to open up this document -- and
get ready because it happens quick.
And there it is.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: Everything just syncs.
And once you've shown the feature, move on
to the next thing.
So that's Google Documents working offline.
It's available today.
We're working on offline presentations and
spreadsheets.
Those are coming soon.
But if you're flying back from Google I/O
and you don't have internet on the plane,
try out Google Docs.
It works great.
So Google Docs offline.
[ Applause ]
>>Clay Bavor: Now, if we could just go to
the Chromebook, Google Documents is just one
application that Google Drive makes possible.
But users can also create and edit and share
all sorts of stuff with dozens and dozens
of third-party applications that have integrated
with Google Drive using the Google Drive SDK.
We've actually just updated our SDK to Version
2 today, and let me show you what's possible
with this SDK.
So as a user I can do is go to the Web store,
add additional apps that integrate with Drive,
and they show up here in the more menu.
So I can fax, I can send and receive faxes
with Hellofax right from Google Drive, so
you can get rid of your fax machine and just
have faxes come straight to Drive.
I can create and edit images and videos and
charts.
And now, the neat thing about the way the
integrations work is files you create with
these third-party applications, they're stored
alongside everything else, just like regular
files.
So I've created a couple of diagrams for Google
I/O, and I just click that.
And notice I don't have to log in or authenticate.
It just launches the file, it opens the application,
takes a couple of seconds, and then we're
in Lucidchart, one of my favorite applications.
This is a really deep statement here.
So one of the neat things about Drive is our
developers -- not only do they get access
to millions and millions of users, authentication,
sharing, Google Drive storage, but they're
telling us that their users that come from
Drive are actually more active than users
that come to their applications directly.
So Lucidchart tells us their users when they
come from Drive, because of the sharing and
ease of creation, create three times more
diagrams.
Hellofax users send 25% more faxes.
SlideRocket users are three and a half times
as likely to create a presentation.
So developers are seeing really, really great
distribution using Drive.
We actually have a session right after this
at 11:45 in Room 8 on the Drive SDK.
Actually, this morning I just whipped up a
little diagram to help get you there in case
you're interested.
Room 8, 11:45.
So that's the Google Drive SDK.
Version 2 is coming out today.
We're really excited about it.
You also saw Google Drive for iOS and for
Chrome OS and Documents now working offline.
So we're really excited about where we're
taking Google Drive.
We hope you will join us.
Thanks very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you, Clay.
So just like Chrome, Google cloud applications,
Google Drive now also works on Windows, Mac,
Android, iOS, Chrome OS, across all your platforms.
and all your devices so that you can live
online on the cloud seamlessly.
So we are very excited by that.
Quite a few years ago, we set out on this
journey to really help users live in the cloud,
to design an end-to-end computing experience.
And that's what the Chrome OS journey is all
about.
A year ago, at Google I/O, we launched our
first-generation Chromebooks.
Our goal was to get the product out there,
help seed the market, get feedback from developers
like you.
Since then, we've been hard at work.
We release a version of the operating system
every six weeks and automatically update it
to all Chromebooks out there.
There are no versions, no downloads, no installs.
We constantly update them.
We brought it all together about three weeks
ago for the next-generation Chromebooks.
There are three main aspects to it.
First of all, they're significantly faster.
They are about 3X faster than the first-generation
Chromebooks, thanks to faster processors.
And the entire software stack is now hardware
accelerated, so it's really fast and smooth,
as fast as in computers which are around $1,000.
It has a full end-to-end user experience.
You saw a bit of that earlier.
It is -- it treats applications as first-class
citizens.
So you're no longer tied to a browser window.
You can have full screen experiences.
You can have applications side by side, multiple
windows, you can pin them to the task bar,
et cetera.
And we are really investing in the application
ecosystem.
You saw examples with Google Drive working
on it and important applications like Google
Documents now working offline.
One of the things which excites about it is
we call it the "always new" computer.
Since we update it automatically, even people
who bought the first-generation Chromebook,
a lot of them wrote to us three weeks ago
and said they opened their computer, it got
faster, and they have a whole new window manager
at work, just like that.
So we are very excited by the model we are
working on, and we are going to be investing
a lot more here.
One of the feedbacks, the last version was
well received, but more people wanted to get
their hands on and see what these are like.
So as of today, we are going to make Chromebooks
available in physical retail, 100 Best Buy
stores all across the United States.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: So that users can try them
and buy them.
We are doing the same in U.K., with Dixon's
as well.
As we go through the next few months, you're
going to see a lot more.
We are working with many more OEMs and Intel
to get a whole lineup ready for the holiday
season.
So stay tuned.
One of the things when I came to Google in
2004, I was inspired by taking a tour of our
data center.
Just walking inside them and seeing hundreds
and hundreds of computers powering applications
like Google Search, and we had just launched
Gmail, and seeing the scale of the infrastructure
needed was inspiring.
But it is very hard for Web developers externally
to get access to that kind of infrastructure.
We want you to write great Web applications,
so we've been thinking hard about how to provide
you with the same quality of infrastructure
we enjoy at Google.
To do that, I want to invite Urs Hoelzle,
our first V.P. of engineering, one of the
first ten employees at Google, and the person,
more than anyone, responsible for building
all of Google's infrastructure.
Urs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: Thank you, Sundar.
We've heard a great many things today about
applications, clients, and -- but I'm here
today to talk about servers and the infrastructure
that powers all these applications.
A long time ago, at Google, we started working
very hard to build the world's fastest, most
scalable, and most reliable infrastructure.
We needed our infrastructure to deliver incredible
scale and incredible performance at a very
low cost.
And over the years, we built one of the world's
largest set of data centers and one of the
world's largest networks to connect these
data centers.
And then we started looking at ways to deliver
that infrastructure to you so that you can
build great applications for your users.
So in 2008, we launched App Engine.
App Engine lets you write simple, intuitive
code to build your apps.
And then we take them and we manage them and
we scale them for you.
So if you have one request per second or 1,000
requests per second, it just works.
We're thrilled about the popularity of App
Engine.
Today, it's supporting over 1 million active
applications, 7.5 billion hits per day every
day, and 2 trillion data store operations
per month.
That easily makes it the largest public, NoSQL
data store infrastructure in the world.
[ Applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: Thank you.
So more and more developers are using App
Engine.
And every day, we hear success stories from
them.
Here's one from Japan, where earlier this
month, a fully one-third of Japan was watching
a national song contest.
And App Engine was powering the live streaming
and the voting for this event.
At its peak, it ran at 24,000 requests per
second.
Yet, no other App Engine user noticed that
this was going on.
So the ability to sail through this kind of
traffic spike allows you to focus on your
application while we focus on handling the
traffic.
So we're very proud of what App Engine has
enabled all of you developers to do.
But many of you have said you want even more
options.
And, specifically, you've told us that you
want virtual machines on demand with industry-leading
performance, with industry-leading scalability,
and so easy and cheap to run that you'd prefer
them to your in-house servers.
Well, today, I'm going to show you what it
is like to run in Google's cloud.
I'm here to announce Google Compute Engine,
infrastructure as a service that delivers
the kind of performance --
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: -- and scale and value --
[ Applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: You haven't seen anything yet.
Thanks.
[ Laughter ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: But the infrastructure as a
service that delivers the performance and
scale and value that only Google can deliver.
So Compute Engine gives you Linux virtual
machines at Google scale.
Spin up two VMs or 10,000 VMs.
It just works.
You have multiple storage options, high-performance
networking between VMs so that you can form
them into a cluster and great connectivity
to your end users using Google's global backbone.
So let me show what Compute Engine and App
Engine together can do.
One of our beta testers was the Institute
for Systems Biology.
The ISB uses genomic analysis to decipher
how genes function and to find relationships
between the genes that signal the potential
for new cancer drugs.
They wrote an App Engine app that connected
to Compute Engine virtual machines.
And you'll see it here on the screen here.
They show the human genome in a circular form.
And the application allows researchers to
visually explore the associations between
genes, mutations, and other factors.
And each of these associations is shown with
a blue line like that.
Now, this may look simple, but this kind of
analysis requires a tremendous amount of computation.
So ISB built an in-house cluster with 1,000
nodes to handle this kind of computation.
Yet it still took them ten minutes to compute
just a single association using the entire
cluster.
So, fortunately, it took only a few days to
port this application to Compute Engine.
And let's see how Compute Engine performs
on this application.
Now, remember, on their in-house 1,000-core
cluster, what you would see here is one line
appear, you know, click, and then you'd wait
for ten minutes to see the next line.
So let's see what Compute Engine can do with
this.
(Ticking).
>>Urs Hoelzle: All right.
So this is what happens when you add 10,000
cores to your application.
Instead of it taking ten minutes, you get
a new association every few seconds.
That's the kind of scalability and performance
that Google can deliver.
And so today, anyone with large-scale computing
needs can now access this same infrastructure
with Compute Engine virtual machines.
And this infrastructure comes with a scale
and a performance and a value that is unparalleled
in the industry, because you benefit from
the efficiency of Google data centers and
our decade of experience in running them.
What you get from Google is not just the scale,
but also amazing stable performance.
So our virtual machines and storage are predictably
fast so you can rely on a consistent level
of performance, no matter who else is running
on Compute Engine right now, just as App Engine
was able to handle a huge spike in the Japanese
application.
For example, when Invite Media ported their
ad server from another cloud provider to Compute
Engine, they were able to double the number
of connections that each single VM can accept
at -- using VMs of comparable size, and, more
importantly, they were able to reduce the
number of connection errors by over a factor
of ten because of the predictable performance.
You can hear more directly from Compute Engine
beta users in the technical sessions about
Compute Engine which you will see show up
on your I/O calendar after this talk.
So be sure to check them out.
Now, finally, we know that you want top scalability
and top performance.
But you also need value.
And Compute Engine is a great value, delivering
up to 50% more compute per dollar than other
cloud providers, so you don't have to choose
between getting the best performance and getting
the best price.
We worked very hard for a decade to lower
the cost of computing, and we're passing these
savings on to you.
[ Applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: Compute Engine is now open
in limited preview.
And it's amazing to finally be able to talk
about this.
It's amazing to see 10,000 cores working for
a single application and what that can do.
So 10,000 cores, I think that's really cool.
But you know what really cool?
[ Laughter ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: Well, we know that some of
you need even more scale.
And we have the technology to help you.
For computations that are very, very computationally
intensive but don't need that much I/O, we
can scale much, much higher.
You may have noticed this ticker counting
up since the start of my presentation.
Well, this ticker is not a conceptual counter.
It shows the actual count of the number of
cores available to the genome app right now.
And they've all been adding since the beginning
of this presentation.
So what would you say to 770,000 cores available
to your app?
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: So if you're ISB, you would
say, actually, my app kind of taps out at
600,000 cores.
It doesn't scale any further.
So let's leave 170,000 idle and allocate 600,000
to the genome app and see how fast it runs.
Switch to the app.
Right.
There's a little initial delay.
And then we really get going.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: So this is the same computation
now running on 600,000 cores.
That is cool!
[ Laughter ]
>>Urs Hoelzle: And that is how Infrastructure
as a Service is supposed to work.
So this, ladies and gentlemen, truly is the
best time ever to deliver and to build for
the Web.
You now have access to the scale and performance
of Google's infrastructure at a great price.
And it's up to you to figure out how to make
the best use of that.
So with that, back to Sundar.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Woo-hoo!
I was jumping up back there when I saw the
600,000 cores, the kind of scale you can only
dream about.
It's incredibly exciting that you all now
have access to what we have had internally
at Google.
I can't wait to see what you all build next.
Of course, infrastructure is only one component
of writing great Web applications.
The other thing is the actual underlying platform.
And we've been working hard with a lot of
you and other browser vendors and the open
Web community to advance that forward.
What you're seeing behind me -- let's switch
to the visualization, please.
What you're seeing behind me is the visualization
of how the Web platform was evolved over the
years.
It's inspiring and humbling to see names like
Mosaic, Netscape, the introduction of HTML,
CSS.
But what's interesting is, as you go to the
far right, you can see it gets denser.
It's much richer.
That's because the Web platform is evolving
at a faster pace than ever before, which makes
sense, because the Web is increasingly being
used across many, many new types of devices:
Phone, tablets, and so on.
And we need to make sure we have all the Web
to support those use cases.
The good news is, it's happening very fast.
One of the great things about the Web is,
as we add APIs, developers like you immediately
take advantage of it to write great Web applications.
So let me give one example.
About a year and a half ago, from the Chrome
team, we decided to support games, rich games,
online.
Why?
Games tend to push the limits of a platform.
They are really hard on the platform.
And if you can run games, you can pretty much
do anything else.
So we talked to game developers, and we found
out what APIs they need.
A lot of it was what we were already working
on.
And we started adding them to Chrome.
So let's take a look at what's happening.
So let's switch to a game.
Kan is going to help me with it.
What we are showing you -- can you switch
to the game, please.
What we are showing you is a game called Gaikai,
which is being streamed.
It's a service called Gaikai.
This is being streamed live online.
And they can do it to any Internet-connected
devices.
There is no download.
There is no install.
You just click and play different games.
This particular game is called Bulletstorm.
And I've been assured all do you is shoot
aliens in this process.
So let's take a look.
So Kan is going to load up the game and play.
What you will notice is that, first of all,
it's a rich, full-screen experience.
It's very immersive.
We do it through the full-screen API.
The sound effects are all enhanced audio APIs
we have added in the last year.
To do a game like this, you need really good
performance.
You need raw network access.
We do it through UDP.
The local performance on the client you see
there is being done because we are executing
in the native client sandbox.
And, finally, to do something like this, obviously,
Kan is using a game pad.
We needed to give access to a peripheral like
the game pad with a game pad API.
Doing that, you can see a rich game.
By the way, it's running in a Chromebook.
You can spin it around because everything
is hardware accelerated.
It's not just Gaikai and Bulletstorm which
have done this, we have -- let's switch to
the slides -- we have seen several mainstream
games, Angry Birds, cut the rope, all available
in the Chrome Web Store.
In fact, even Triple A console-style games
like Bastion, From Dust, are all available
in the Web Store now to play.
Angry Birds alone has been played by more
than 140 million users.
What's happening in games is happening in
every other vertical in the Web Store: Games,
entertainment, like music, educational apps,
and apps for businesses as well.
Over 750 million applications have been installed,
and people are enjoying living online in the
cloud every day.
And we are just getting started.
We are going to evolve Chrome apps pretty
significantly.
There are three major areas we are going to
focus on.
First is we need to make sure all applications
are always available.
You saw the example of Docs offline.
As you write a Chrome application, we are
going to provide developers with a way to
package resources automatically by default,
including the UI, so that you can always serve
the application locally.
The second thing is, we want to make sure
you get an authentic app experience, just
like what you saw with the game earlier.
So we want to break out of the browser window
when you want to give full-screen experiences,
as well as provide new UI containers for applications.
And, finally, when you write a Chrome application,
we want to make sure you have access to every
underlying device API across phones, tablets,
and desktops.
So we are working hard at that.
If you download the Chrome canary build, you
can see what we are doing there.
And we have sessions later in the day where
you can get a lot more details.
It is one thing to write great Web applications.
But it is an entirely different thing to take
a real-world experience, something with amazing
artistry, like what Cirque du Soleil creates,
and translate that to the cloud.
Something very hard to do, and to share that
journey, let me invite Joanne and Aubrey from
Cirque du Soleil.
[ Music ]
>>Joanne Fillion: Thank you, Sundar.
Hello, everyone.
It's great to be here.
For those of you who know Cirque du Soleil,
and I hope many of you do, you will understand
that we always strive to create immersive
and fantastical experiences for our patrons,
experiences that will make them dream for
a little while.
We also constantly ask ourselves, how do we
evolve beyond the live world?
How do we create experiences that reach more
people?
How do we create worlds that people participate
in?
The Web is an obvious option, because it can
reach anyone on the planet.
However, we know how difficult it is to transport
anyone into an imaginary world if they can't
actually experience it firsthand.
In this project, we were still facing the
same big question: Could the Web deliver the
experience we envision?
Could the technology give the possibility
to the user to actually interact with the
environment and lose themself in it?
To create this new world, we knew we needed
to go beyond text, pictures, and videos.
We all really wanted to evoke people's emotions,
to awaken their imagination, and to enrich
their lives.
But I have to say, when we saw the preliminary
result of this project, we all got so excited,
we were surprised.
Some of us were actually really touched, and
stunned, I would say, by the depth and the
richness of the visual animation.
The creative team and this new technology
have created an experience that evokes a beautiful,
immersive, and sensorial world that truly
resembles Cirque du Soleil and that can be
enjoyed by everyone when and where they feel
it.
The combination of great creative minds in
this new Web technology opened possibilities
that we didn't know existed before.
I will let Aubrey, our development partner,
to show you what we built together, and, most
importantly probably for you guys, how we
built it.
Aubrey.
[ Applause ]
>>Aubrey Anderson: Thanks, Joanne.
It's awesome.
This is awesome to be here.
Cirque du Soleil in a browser.
What a fantastic challenge.
Let's take a look at our demo and see how
we did.
Now, in order to get you into the experience
in a different way, we allow you to control
the navigation and perspective by moving your
body.
As the experience starts, our tour guide shows
us how to do it.
We've used the Get User Media API inside Web
RTC to enable the user's camera and detect
faces and track motion, and then we map that
back to the navigation controls in the app.
Kan, can you move left and right and show
that behavior.
There he goes.
You'll notice Kan's silhouette at the bottom
as he moves.
This gives him some feedback about where he
is in space.
And then once our guide feels like we've got
the hang of it, she opens up the curtains
and we're invited into her imaginary world.
I love it when something very complex turns
out to be created with simple ingredients.
We've created this world completely in HTML.
We've combined Web video and images and markup
into virtual set pieces which we then position
in 3D space using CSS.
You can see how the elements parallax in response
to Kan's movements.
That's because the elements are each positioned
individually and it creates this very realistic
interactive environment for us to explore.
The HTML elements are then brought to life
with CSS animations and filters individually.
And it's all amazingly fast because of hardware-accelerated
rendering in the browser.
What you're seeing here is all running on
a Chromebook.
After exploring this world, we just need to
follow our guide and take the leap.
And we wanted to accentuate the 3D nature
of this experience with this fall.
You might consider using a plug-in or a WebGL
to accomplish something like this.
But what you're seeing here is just DIVs.
We've used individual CSS animations to spin
the elements and we've used one long 3D transform
--
[ Applause ]
>>Aubrey Anderson: It's cool, isn't it?
[ Laughter ]
>>Aubrey Anderson: We have one long 3D transform
which transforms the whole model.
And at the end of the fall, we splash into
a Vernal Pool where we can enjoy a performance.
Now, to see how this world is actually put
together, let's take a look at the source.
I'm feeling brave.
Kan, can you open up the Chrome developer
tools.
He's totally already done it.
Because this is just markup in the browser,
we can actually manipulate these elements
in real time right while the application is
running.
Here Kan is able to change the rotation property
in the CSS, and the whole model will move
in space.
[ Applause ]
>>Aubrey Anderson: Our navigation controls
will even still work here and just transforms
the elements from their new position.
Now, another great thing about this approach
is that it's wonderfully portable.
For example, it works just as well in a Web
browser on a tablet.
Kan, will you bring up the app on a device.
Look, there it is.
Here, we can take advantage of the unique
capabilities in the device, like the accelerometer
and gestures.
Notice as Kan tilts the device, our perspective
is changing in the same way it changed when
he was tracking to the camera.
And it just happens for us, because CSS is
giving the instructions and we're letting
the hardware accelerated browser in whatever
run time we find ourselves in do all the work.
I hope you've enjoyed this short preview about
what's coming from Cirque du Soleil.
And I hope it highlights the kind of immersive,
beautiful user experience you can create using
the HTML skills I bet most of you already
have in a great browser like Google Chrome.
Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: I've been very impressed
by watching Cirque du Soleil live and watching
that.
It shows you the power of the Web today.
It's been a very exciting journey, and a lot
of it started with Chrome.
And we built it together with our users and
developers like you.
None of what we showed today would have been
possible without the journey of Chrome.
We've put together a short video to recap
what the journey has been like with you all.
So let's take a look.
[ Video.
]
>>> Today I'm going to be talking to you about
HTML5.
Interesting aspects of the new standard.
[ Music ]
>>> Chrome has amazing frame rate capabilities.
>>> Frame rate capabilities.
[ Video concludes.
]
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: So it's been an exciting
journey, and we really need your help to do
what's next.
So we thought the best way to package all
the goodness you saw today and give it to
all of you, and there's no better way for
us to do that than literally give you all
a Chromebox, the brand-new Samsung Chromebox,
which, --
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: -- hopefully, you have some
extra space in your Android developer pack
with -- in addition to the three devices.
So the Web is entirely what you all make of
it.
And we rely on the help of developers like
you to succeed in what we do and help users
live online.
So we hope you can continue to develop a lot
of great Web applications, and we will see
you next year.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
>>> You're on.
>>Sergey Brin: We're live?
We're a go?
Okay.
Hey, everybody.
Welcome here to a beautiful, cool day in San
Francisco.
We're on the roof of the Moscone center.
I know we showed you something really special
yesterday.
And we got so much interest that we wanted
to show you how we put it all together.
And, actually, we wanted to show you some
of the pretty same exciting action that you
saw, but from a new perspective this time.
So you can see, this is the roof.
Some of our bikers are warming up out there.
And they're doing some of their cool tricks,
getting ready for their part of this demonstration.
You can also see that the airship is actually
overhead.
It's pretty close to the sun.
I don't know if we can get a camera on that.
You might be able to see it through my view
through my Glass in the Hangout.
And we actually have a number of the jumpers
in the Hangout now.
Now, as I walk over here, you'll see that
it's actually tricky to keep them in the Hangout
because of the really challenging wireless
environment.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sergey Brin: And if I can show you all on
here, we're pointing each of these dishes,
using different kinds of RF technology for
redundancy.
Each jumper has a different piece of technology
coming down.
And that's how we felt comfortable that we
could maintain at least a couple of them in
the Hangout.
I'm also, by the way, testing out a new kind
of iteration of Glass with these shade clip-ins
here right now.
And they're -- definitely makes it better
out here in the bright sun.
So we're going to have -- we've worked, you
know, with a lot of people around here, with
the City of San Francisco, the FAA, and the
offices of Oakland and San Jose to make this
happen.
But the coordination is pretty tricky, as
you might imagine.
Our jump master is here.
This is marshal.
Marshal, how far out are we?
>>> Under two minutes from the wing suits
being in the air.
>>Sergey Brin: Under two minutes?
That's super exciting.
And you guys might be able to see their perspectives
right now in the Hangout live.
This is pretty exciting to me.
How's -- have you heard from J.T.?
How are they doing up there?
>>> They're in position right now.
They're going to hover a little while, open
the door, they're going to fly in their wing
suits northwest of us here, deploy their parachutes.
And then you and I will be out here and it
will be high fives and smiles when they land.
>>Sergey Brin: Awesome.
Since we only have a couple minutes, why don't
you guys walk with me.
I want to get closer to their landing zone.
And, you know, as we go here, I can just point
out, I mean, it's just stunning here.
But if you look over there, as we walk toward
the landing zone, you can see a fog bank right
over there.
And that fog bank is actually very scary to
us.
It seems to be clearing out, so we feel good
about the jump today.
But there was no guarantee.
And, in fact, I should note that skydiving,
you know, there's no such thing as instrument
skydiving.
You actually have to see your landing.
I guess, conceivably, with Glass, you could
make an instrument version.
You have a nice heads-up display where you're
going.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sergey Brin: But, anyway, we'll have to
try that another time.
I know, I'm scaring my jump master.
Today, we have sunny skies.
You can see -- there's the airship pretty
much straight overhead.
I don't know if we can get -- maybe we'll
get another shot of that.
We have a few cameras scattered here that
can show you that.
And let's keep walking here.
A lot of exciting action.
Now, I don't want to -- I don't want to block
your view.
Hopefully, the audience is seeing right now
-- how is our Hangout going?
>>> We're ready to go up to the airship.
>>> Okay.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
They're ready to jump.
Cool.
How's our view in the Hangout coming along?
>>> I think J.T. is ready.
Go up to J.T.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
That's so cool.
Why don't we throw it up to J.T. and he can
take it away.
And, hopefully, this Hangout will go as well
as yesterday did.
But, you know, you never know.
A million things can go wrong.
Okay, take it away, J.T.
>>> Yeah.
Good to be here, Terry.
Yeah, lucky with that fog.
Good job calling ahead on that one, Sergey,
having it kind of just push away.
Perfect.
>>> It's obviously high up.
It's kind of hard to spot from here if the
door is open.
They'll be slowing down and hovering right
before they exit the aircraft.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay, okay.
>>> A ten-second countdown.
We'll be able to watch the whole show.
>>Sergey Brin: That's exciting.
Thank you so much, Marshal.
>>> Beautiful day for this.
Earlier, when we had the clouds, it was --
>>Sergey Brin: That was definitely touch and
go.
And, you know, I'm so excited about today.
Yesterday was really fun.
But I was down in the auditorium.
And, by the way, for those of you who are
actually watching at I/O, you can see it from
the lobby.
You might not be able to see quite the skydiver
angle, but you'll be able to see some of the
other activity that we have.
For those of you who are in downtown San Francisco,
this would probably be a good time to peek
out your windows.
Do you know if the door is open?
Maybe I'll --
>>> Are you guys ready for us?
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
They are ready.
>>> Sergey, the door (inaudible).
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
All right.
So we're about to -- we're going to see them,
actually, from the door here.
You'll have -- you'll be seeing the first
person shot of them exiting.
For those of you in San Francisco who are
looking from the Moscone area, it's the back
door on the port side of the ship.
We should get a countdown momentarily.
They're hovering.
You can see they're pretty much right over
the intercontinental hotel.
And Marshal, who's going to run the countdown?
Neal, on the airship is going to be counting
down.
The door is open.
>>> Good morning, San Francisco!
Hey, how are the winds doing down there?
All right.
Well, we're going for it.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
We've got 30 seconds, everyone.
I'm super excited about this.
>>> See you in a few.
>>Sergey Brin: Almost straight overhead.
It's a beautiful day.
We're really lucking out that the fog is holding
back.
Door is open.
Pretty much standing still right now.
>>> Just going that way.
God, that --
>>Sergey Brin: That must be a beautiful feeling
to just fly right out of there.
>>> Five, four, three -- one!
>>> Jumping away.
>>Sergey Brin: There they are!
There they are!
You can see them flying.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sergey Brin: They're soaring across the
sky.
Look at that.
They're weaving closely in and out of each
other.
The Hangout footage, I'm sorry, I don't have
it.
It must be beautiful.
Their chutes are opening.
We've got two chutes open.
And the third one, with a puff of smoke, just
opened.
If you're wondering why, we had to put one
of them with a puff of smoke so the radio-aiming
folks could know which skydiver was theirs.
>>> Walk over here and get -- we'll try to
get (indiscernible) as they land.
>>Sergey Brin: Yes, if we can get over this
way pretty quick, and, hopefully, you guys
can tag along.
Okay, bikers ready.
You can see we're getting ready.
Skydivers coming down.
All right.
Where should I stand here?
>>> Going to land right --
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
You can see them clearly.
You can now --
>>> Give us 30 feet or so.
>>Sergey Brin: All right.
>>> Step right over here.
They're going to be landing, coming towards
us.
>>> Here comes J.T. right here.
>>> All right.
>>Sergey Brin: Woo-hoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>> Yeah, buddy.
Yeah, all right!
[ Applause ]
>>Sergey Brin: Incoming.
>>> Whoa all right!
Nice!
>>Sergey Brin: That was awesome.
>>> Thanks for having us.
>>Sergey Brin: Thanks for coming down.
All right.
That was amazing.
>>> Good job.
>>Sergey Brin: All of our jumpers are down.
And they make it look so easy.
All right.
Don't get blown away here.
Hey, hey, that was great.
Thanks, again.
Amazing jump.
Thanks, guys.
>>> (indiscernible).
>>> That was awesome.
>>Sergey Brin: Great job.
All right, thanks, guys, so much.
Now, don't forget, we tested -- that was an
amazing jump.
We have more in store to show you just how
did we do it.
We have our excellent bikers here.
And this is a really fun area here.
There are a few kind of natural blocks and
things.
But the killer thing that we put in there,
because the roof goes up and down, there's
a really great ramp that we put in there.
And that was where you saw that magical moment.
So maybe we can actually get a chance to see
the bikers -- let's see what you guys got!
Why don't you hit the ramp.
All right.
And we're going to try to make our way so
we can first of all watch this.
Watch this.
Yeah!
Whoa, another back flip.
That was amazing.
All right.
We're going to head over now and try to catch
them on the other side.
The roof goes, actually, up, and then there's
the giant dropoff on the other side.
Yesterday, they cruised right through that.
But today, we're going to get ourselves time
to get over there so we can have a really
nice view.
So please follow along.
Now, we're going to have to go through some
of the deep, dark, cavernous parts of the
building.
And we're going to try to hustle there and
get there pretty quick.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sergey Brin: And okay, this time today,
because we're not in such a hurry, the bikers
are going to wait for us.
If you haven't seen the inside of Moscone,
it's a pretty exciting sight.
So let's make our way through.
So are we keeping running right now?
Okay.
But --
>>> We can all the way through.
>>Sergey Brin: Okay.
(Radio communication).
I don't know if you guys can follow here.
I'm going to unclip my shades now so I can
see a little bit better.
And this is just a portion of all the equipment
that powers this building.
We actually -- when we were talking about
this originally, we looked at having people
bike and jump up and down through here.
Okay.
I'm going to -- oh, thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
These might work a little bit better for me.
I'm going to click my -- these shade clip-ins
to this other pair of glasses here and just
-- it's a little accessory that we're working
on.
And it's pretty nice on a bright day like
this.
So here we are.
And -- actually, it's kind of cool, because
I don't know if you guys can see me right
now.
I'm now in a Hangout.
Back on the other side, had a little bit of
issues keeping me in the Hangout.
But here it's working nicely.
And here we can make our way, we can check
this out.
Maybe we'll -- if you guys can follow along
with me, we can see the bikers are right up
there.
It's a really big drop, actually.
It's a really big drop.
I'm going to duck under here.
And it's a -- I mean, I know they make it
look easy.
But they're probably, what, 15 feet up there?
And they're going to just show us how they
get down off that big ramp.
All right, guys.
Let's see you go.
>>> Go, go, go!
>>> They're hitting the drop.
>>> All right.
See you down there.
>>Sergey Brin: You can see that they're -- we've
got three, actually.
And it's a long way down.
It's a long way down.
I'm actually going to take off my Glass so
you can see this.
Okay.
Now, hopefully, they've made it down safe
and sound.
[ Applause ]
>>Sergey Brin: Hopefully, it tracked.
We're going to make our way downstairs, too,
and catch up with you.
Thank you, all, for watching.
I know we have a lot of interest.
And we just wanted to show for the people
who just, you know, heard about it just yesterday,
want to show you about something that it took
and actually show you some of that amazing
action again.
All right.
Well, we'll keep you abreast of our progress
on Glass.
This is just one of the exciting things that
we've had the privilege of working on and
that -- I'm hoping this is going to lead to
something really exciting going forward.
[ Applause ]
>>Sergey Brin: All right.
[ Music ]